Sur Wikipédia, j'ai appris que la calotte glaciaire du Groenland est énorme,
de la taille du Mexique,
et que sa glace fait plus de trois kilomètres d'épaisseur.
Mais elle n'est pas immobile.
La glace coule comme une rivière et descend vers l'océan.
Tandis qu'elle épouse les méandres,
elle se déforme et craque.
J'étudie ces incroyables évolutions glaciaires
situées dans l'un des environnements physiques les plus isolés
restant sur la Terre.
Travailler dans la glaciologie aujourd'hui,
c'est comme faire partie des débuts de Facebook dans les années 2000.
(Rires)
Notre capacité de piloter avions et satellites au-dessus de la glace
a révolutionné la glaciologie, et commence juste à faire pour la science,
ce que le smartphone a fait pour les réseaux sociaux.
Les satellites rapportent une mine d'informations
révélant, en continu, des données inédites à propos des calottes glaciaires.
Nous avons des informations sur la taille de la calotte glaciaire du Groenland
tous les mois depuis 2002.
Vous pouvez regarder en bas de l'écran
pour voir les mois et les années avancer.
Certains endroits de la calotte glaciaire fondent
ou perdent de la glace en été.
D'autres connaissent des chutes de neige ou retrouvent de la glace en hiver.
Ce cycle saisonnier est toutefois éclipsé par un taux général de perte de masse
qui aurait sidéré un glaciologue il y a 50 ans.
Nous n'avons jamais imaginé qu'une calotte glaciaire
pouvait perdre de sa masse dans l'océan si rapidement.
Depuis que ces mesures ont débuté en 2002,
la calotte glaciaire a perdu tant de glace
que si on empilait cette eau sur notre continent le plus petit,
l'Australie serait inondée jusqu'aux genoux.
Comment est-ce possible ?
Eh bien, sous la calotte glaciaire se trouve le socle rocheux.
Avec un radar, nous avons cartographié les collines, les vallées,
les montagnes et les dépressions que la glace recouvre.
Cachés sous la calotte glaciaire, des canaux de la taille du Grand Canyon
acheminent la glace et l'eau du Groenland jusqu'à l'océan.
Un radar peut révéler le socle rocheux
parce que la glace est entièrement transparente aux ondes radar.
Vous pouvez faire une expérience : à la maison,
placez un glaçon dans le micro-ondes.
Il ne fondra pas,
parce que les micro-ondes, ou les ondes radars,
passent à travers la glace sans la transformer.
Pour faire fondre votre glaçon, vous devez le mouiller,
parce que l'eau chauffe facilement dans le micro-ondes.
C'est là tout le principe autour duquel le micro-onde a été créé.
Un radar peut voir l'eau.
Et un radar a révélé un immense réservoir d'eau liquide
enfouie sous ma collègue Olivia, sept étages sous ses pieds.
Elle a utilisé ici une pompe
pour ramener un peu de cette eau à la surface de la calotte glaciaire.
Il y a six ans, nous n'avions aucune idée de l'existence de cet aquifère glaciaire.
L'aquifère s'est formé lors de la fonte des neiges sous le soleil d'été
et s'écoule en suivant la pente.
Il forme d'énormes réservoirs.
De là, la neige fait office d'igloo,
isolant cette eau du froid et du vent.
L'eau peut ainsi rester cachée dans la calotte glaciaire,
sous sa forme liquide, année après année.
La question est, que se passe-t-il après ?
L'eau reste-t-elle là pour toujours - elle le pourrait -
ou trouve-t-elle une voie pour atteindre les océans mondiaux ?
L'une des voies possibles permettant à l'eau d'atteindre le socle rocheux
et de là, l'océan,
c'est une crevasse ou une fissure dans la glace.
Lorsqu'elles se remplissent d'eau,
le poids de l'eau les rendent de plus en plus profondes.
C'est ainsi que la fracturation opère pour extraire le gaz naturel
des profondeurs de la Terre : les liquides pressurisés fracturent la roche.
Il ne faut qu'une fissure pour démarrer.
Nous avons récemment découvert
qu'il existe des fissures dans la calotte glaciaire du Groenland
près de cet aquifère glaciaire.
Vous pouvez en survoler la plus grande part sans rien y voir :
ni fissure, ni élément particulier à la surface.
Mais tandis que cet hélicoptère se dirige vers la côte,
en suivant le chemin que prendrait l'eau dans sa descente,
une fissure apparaît,
puis une autre, et encore une autre.
Ces fissures sont-elles remplies d'eau liquide ?
Et si oui, à quelle profondeur amènent-elles cette eau ?
Peuvent-elle l'acheminer jusqu'au substrat rocheux et à l'océan ?
Pour répondre à ces questions,
nous avons besoin de quelque chose qui dépasse les données de télédétection.
Nous avons besoin de modèles numériques.
J'écris des modèles numériques pour superordinateurs.
Un modèle numérique est juste une série d'équations
qui s'associent pour décrire quelque chose.
Il peut être aussi simple que le nombre suivant dans une série -
un, trois, cinq, sept -
ou il peut être une série d'équations plus complexe
qui prédit le futur en fonction des conditions connues dans le présent.
Dans notre cas, quelles sont les équations pour expliquer la fissure de la glace ?
Les ingénieurs comprennent déjà très bien
comment l'aluminium, l'acier et le plastique se fracturent sous pression.
C'est un problème important dans notre société.
Il s'avère que les équations techniques expliquant la fracture des matériaux
ne sont pas si différentes de mes devoirs de physique.
Donc, je les ai empruntés et adaptés à la glace,
et j'ai obtenu le modèle numérique de la façon dont une crevasse se fracture
lorsqu'elle est remplie d'eau provenant de l'aquifère.
C'est le pouvoir des maths.
Ils peuvent nous aider à comprendre les processus du monde réel.
Je vais vous montrer les résultats de mon modèle numérique.
Mais d'abord, je dois signaler que la crevasse
est environ mille fois plus étroite qu'elle n'est profonde,
donc sur le graphique principal,
nous avons zoomé pour mieux voir les détails.
Vous pouvez regarder la colonne de droite
pour connaître l'échelle réelle de cette crevasse, sa hauteur et sa minceur.
En se déversant dans la crevasse,
une partie de l'eau de l'aquifère se recongèle dans la glace à -15 °C.
C'est à peu près aussi froid que votre congélateur.
Mais cette perte peut être surmontée
si le débit en provenance de l'aquifère est suffisamment élevé.
Dans notre cas, il l'est,
et l'eau de l'aquifère pousse la crevasse jusqu'à la base de la calotte glacière,
mille mètres plus bas.
De là, la voie est libre pour atteindre l'océan.
L'eau de l'aquifère contribue donc en partie
à l'élévation du niveau de la mer de trois millimètres par an
dont nous faisons tous l'expérience dans notre société mondiale.
Mais, ce n'est pas tout :
l'eau de l'aquifère pourrait exercer plus d'influence.
L'écoulement de la glace est un phénomène complexe.
Dans certains endroits, elle s'écoule très rapidement.
On peut alors trouver de l'eau à la base de la calotte glaciaire.
Ailleurs, elle est plus lente,
et en général, on ne trouve pas d'eau à la base dans ce cas.
Maintenant que nous savons que l'eau de l'aquifère atteint la base de la calotte,
la question est :
cela fait-il couler la glace elle-même plus rapidement dans l'océan ?
Nous essayons de découvrir ces mystères
cachés dans la calotte glaciaire du Groenland,
pour mieux anticiper l'élévation du niveau de la mer qu'elle contient.
La quantité de glace que le Groenland a perdu depuis 2002
n'est qu'une petite fraction de ce que contient cette calotte glaciaire.
Les calottes glaciaires sont de puissantes machines
qui fonctionnent sur de longues durées.
Au cours des 80 prochaines années,
le niveau global des océans augmentera d'au moins 20 cm,
peut-être jusqu'à un mètre, peut-être plus.
Notre compréhension de l'élévation du niveau de la mer est adéquate
mais nos projections ont un large spectre.
C'est notre rôle en tant que glaciologues et scientifiques
de réduire ces incertitudes.
Quel sera le taux d'élévation du niveau de la mer
et à quelle vitesse se produira-t-il ?
Nous devons connaître la quantité et la vitesse
afin que le monde et ses communautés puissent se préparer
à la prochaine élévation du niveau de la mer.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)